mukbang
has it been three years how long has it
been mukbang was the new genre that took
youtube by storm in 2018 so popular that
it made it to youtube rewind why we i
want to eat something mukbang
mukbang yeah korea let's do it korea
staff
it's fun it's innocent but of course
then youtubers come in and they gotta
take everything to the to the next level
to the extreme not that i've ever done
that of course what is this thumbnail
i gotta hand it to uh mukbang channels
they always know how to make a good
thumbnail
does anyone actually click on that and
be like oh are we
i can't wait to see her eat all day uh
mukbang for those who don't know is
basically just people eating food on
camera you know even though i know that
anytime i click on the video and all i
hear is
right this for example
i really shouldn't be surprised right
it is what it is
this is one of those things where like
that can't be it people just eat they oh
wait that's it okay all right well like
i mentioned before youtubers come in and
they always take it too far it's sort of
become a trend to eat the nastier the
food looks the more sort of interesting
i guess people click on it they want to
see this is called mukbang asmr if asmr
is supposed to be something nice and
pleasant this is doing the exact
opposite for me i don't know what you
would call that
oh that's mr krabs no
oh mr krabs
i hate it i hate it i hate it i hate i
hate it so much youtube please
bring it back um
oh god she's one of those youtubers that
like all the comments so that you can't
tell what people actually think
it's really good youtube removed the
dislikes and now they have this
there's nothing left she likes all the
good ones so they show up right whatever
i don't care it's so gross i get i i
love seafood but this is nasty dude stop
it i don't know what it is with like
young asian girls eating really nasty
food why
stop
stop it we're not watching that i've
decided you're welcome then of course
there's this this happened in 2019 after
i made my video and it's just uh
it's just wild octopus attacks live
streamer as she try to eat it alive in
china
jesus christ this feels like straight
out of nightmare this is stuff i that
shows up in my dreams and i go oh go you
wake up and you're like oh god thank god
that didn't happen i never thought i'd
actually root for the
octopus looks like the first
accomplishment great in his life it
would be an inspiration for generations
to come
you can do it man come on man
may this octopus rest in peace for being
a great hero that's right i actually
agree
no
[Music]
but it didn't end well
but she's playing it up
right haha look it's sucking my face off
haha so funny
but she later begins to panic yeah no
no
yeah
[Music]
my skin is broken i will eat it in my
next video my face is disfigured the
industrial revolution and its
consequences
to be fair there are some funny mukbangs
like the guy that did the cheese thing
that was funny right
[Music]
[Applause]
bro just turn it off jesus christ i love
when he actually managed to do it too
[Laughter]
nice
but some good doesn't outweigh the bag
oh god this girl again
[Music]
dislike button bring it back thank you
comments turn off
[ __ ] god damn it but this like button i
still i'd say it still hurts man i know
listen i know it's a [ __ ] fish who
gives a [ __ ] right but still there's so
there is someone mistreating an animal
at the end of the day i don't mean to be
real morals moral poor but like it's
done on camera in front of millions of
people and it's fine apparently and it's
it's also weird like i'm not allowed to
say what i actually think about this
without youtube coming in and being like
that's bullying you can't say that and
we also have this girl i guess she's
like the last boss i don't know what she
eats and i don't know what i don't want
to know what she eats
what is that
don't answer only wrong answers are
allowed
she always pours a sauce on too that
does not make it better
she eats like it's chinese propaganda
oh so good
so she tries to pull out the snail thing
i don't know what it is i don't don't
care i don't care stop telling me
so she can't get it out so she just
tries to like again pour the [ __ ]
sauce on it
and then bite it
she clearly can't bite it now like what
are you doing here i don't want to know
what that is i don't know that's
fermented soy beans i actually know what
that is that's the japanese thing i
don't know why they eat that
yeah yeah all right anyway long story
short i hate it now uh i made this video
by mukbang three years ago and
there was two youtubers i brought up one
of them was nikata avocado neck i wanted
to check in
see how they're doing
is from 2018. let's check them out today
where's that roof raise that roof
[Music]
it's funny he's trying to sell his own
clothing that he doesn't even fit into
him
nicado avocado is the american final
boss of mukbang i gotta hand it to him
like no one does uh thumbnails better
than ricardo avocado because someone
else can go from the spiciest instant
noodles in the world to
we broke up extreme fire noodle
challenge with hungary i feel like i
always hear something going on in the
background of nikata avocado and i just
cannot be bothered to figure out what is
actually happening but i do remember he
did he did a response to my video and
you know at least you know he i know he
can laugh at himself he's not taking it
too seriously my viewers i'm not doing
this for life once i hit 30 i'm done i'm
going back to a healthy diet
so i i remember that he said once i'm 30
he's done he's uh he's 29 now
i feel like if he manages to just like
lose all his weight and come back super
ripped that would be the funniest that
would be such a funny conclusion to his
whole
saga of degeneracy i don't know what to
call it
i literally keep revisiting this channel
every once in a while to see if you
still
i feel like that's the whole reason we
made this video i'm like i wonder what
they're doing oh it's the same old thing
except it's blue now i really appreciate
the coke zero as well it's good it's
good to cut down on your calories
sometimes
we just put a huge dent into this
i guess my final take on mukbang is said
i hate it it grosses me out clearly
people like it anything youtube related
is gonna be uh
exploited to the max i guess you could
say i just find it weird how
this kind of stuff youtube is just and
i'm not saying they should do anything
about i'm just saying observing how it
works like this is all fine like it's
treating animals just
blatantly promoting obesity i know
they're not condoning it especially in
nicaragua it hasn't never condoned it
but you know it has its effect that
still kids are impressionable right as
someone who's tried dealt with so much
censorship on this platform it's like
what
really i'm just baffled by it i'm not
saying i did i i disagree with it
existing at all this is weird when you
find these different corners on youtube
and like oh this is fine oh wow okay
anyway what do you think let me know in
the comments
smash like subscribe and you could win a
billion dollars
subscribe now you could